welcome back to new rockstars I'm marina
Mastro's Eric lost a bet this week so
now I get to break down the mandalorian
chapter 5 the gunslinger but before we
start a reminder that eric has been
going back through each Star Wars film
pointing out new overlooked details in
analysis you didn't think about starting
with rogue one it's a really good video
check it out if you haven't already by
clicking the link in the description
okay here we go with episode 5 of the
Mandalorian there was a lot of nostalgia
and missable details in this episode so
I'm gonna do my best to fill Eric's big
old man shoes let's go first things
first
big spoiler warning okay got it we
opened with the Mandalorian and baby
Yoda in a makeshift car seat being
chased by another bounty hunter this guy
has the gall to use mandos own line on
him bring it warm
reckon began cold pilot move and kills
him that's my line by the tower who lets
us know that he's going to Mos Eisley
the city of scum and villainy where
obi-wan takes Luke in a new hope
that's right baby we're on Tatooine and
then the statue just keeps coming the
voice of the most Eisley spaceport
operator is none other than Steve Blum
voice actor known for playing Zeb
Aurelio's on Star Wars rebels mando
lands and we see some picture it's from
the pod races in Phantom Menace tried to
repair his ship he blasts at them cos
mando hates droids and we see a
curly-haired Amy Sedaris playing a
loveable mechanic Pelle moto we also get
a quick scene of her playing what looks
like soo bahk with her droids which of
course is the game that Han famously won
against Lando Calrissian to gain the
Millennium Falcon in solo Pelle also
calls mando a womp rat womp rat which
mando affectionately called baby Yoda in
Episode four of the Mandalorian womp rat
and is originally a reference to what
Luke described shooting 16 moving on
mando is still very much learning how to
be a baby daddy because he's straight-up
leaves baby Yoda alone in his ship with
every boundary hunter in the galaxy
after them bad mando bad get a baby
backpack and take your little buddy with
you dum-dum don't leave them in your hot
car with the windows up with a bad-dog
parent you
anyway the mandalorian needs more cash
to pay for his ship to be fixed so we
all start screaming as he walks in to
the cantina to find work it's a little
less crowded in there this time and
actually the streets of Mos Eisley are
also pretty empty too in George Lucas's
original 1977 edition of Star Wars the
streets weren't very populated because
he couldn't afford extras or costumes in
later editions he filled the streets
with CGI characters so this episode
making them empty again kind of throws
us back to that original 1977 feel of a
sleepy western town but times have still
changed because instead of not serving
droids there's now a droid serving the
drinks it distillery tanks behind the
bar are as they were in the original a
new hope props made from the heads of
the IG assassin droids that appeared in
Empire Strikes Back that was ig-88
and in Episode one of the Mandalorian
that's IG eleven inside the cantina we
see a couple of Eevee series droids
Manning the bar Java employed one of
these droids Evie 99 to supervise his
droid staff in Return of the Jedi and if
you look closely you'll also catch the
little red r2 unit with the bad
motivator from Episode four running
around on Tatooine as well moving on the
droid bartender says the bounty guild no
longer operates on Tatooine and then we
meet Toro calcanei young bounty hunter
sitting exactly where Han Solo is
sitting where the now-famous McConkey
blaster battle took place
they must have repainted because there's
no blaster marks on the walls but he
does have his feet up on the table just
like Han did now we hear talk of credits
all the time in Star Wars movies but
it's very rare that we actually see what
currency looks like in a galaxy far far
away so far the Mandalorian has shown us
what imperial credits look like it's a
thick silver bar of metal and now we
know what New Republic credits look like
Toro holds one as he calls out to mando
in the cantina
these gold coins stamped with the rebel
insignia appear to be what's in
circulation now that the Empire has been
overthrown and the Republic has been
restored
Toro offers mando a job helping him
bring in Fennec Shand played by the
fabulous ming-na wen Toro really wants
to just get into the guild so he's
willing to let Mentos keep all of the
bounty and off they hop onto old Zephyr
G swoop bikes from Attack of the Clones
they have a very cool journey across the
dunes see and run into Tusken Raiders
guys this is just nostalgia washing over
you
over and over again mando negotiates
passage and they run into a do back with
its rider dragging behind this turns out
to be a trap set by fennec there is a
lot of details to cover in this episode
so before I continue this episode is
brought to you by audible and their
unmatched selection of audiobooks and
other audio products it's the time of
year when people are traveling or
running around trying to get thoughtful
gifts for the people that they care
about think about giving yourself the
gift of audible membership now is the
best time to do it with a special offer
of 53 percent off your first three
months membership includes one free
audiobook a month exclusive sales and 30
percent off all regularly priced
audiobooks unlike a streaming or rental
service with audible you own your own
books
I got resistance reborn on audible it's
a prequel to Star Wars the rise of
Skywalker and it's about Poe Raven and
the other heroes of the resistance
fighting back from the edge of oblivion
who doesn't love a good fight back from
the edge of oblivion one of the cool
features of audible is that you can
adjust narration speed listen faster
slower sometimes I like to listen to
faster speeds to channel my inner Eric
Foss and consume all of the content
right now for a limited time you can get
three months of audible for just 695 a
month that's more than half off the
regular price visit audible.com slash
new rock stars or text new rockstars -
500 500 okay back to it
mando and Toro wait for nightfall
because mando points out that she has
the high ground which is a nod to the
scene in Revenge of the Sith where
obi-wan tells Anakin
Veronica which has inspired countless
memes across the world they have a
pretty cool battle with flares and
sniper shots
Finnick kicks Toros ass but they do
manage to capture her now this is
important in a conversation with fennec
we find out that the planet where grief
and the client originally hired mando to
find baby Oda the one where he escaped
from the bounty guild in a very cool
battle with help from the other
Mandalorians is actually called Navarro
now it has name that's all just has a
name now okay cool when mando leaves to
find the Dewback because one of the
speeders gets busted fennec convinces
her oh that mando is actually worth more
than she is
Toro agrees but shoots her wanting to
keep all the glory for himself honestly
he's such an idiot I'll admit I was
pretty pissed at this part because I
thought it was a waste of a great
but more on that later man defines
fennecs body and heads back to Mos
Eisley on the Dewback which probably
honestly isn't really that much faster
than walking but in the meantime Toro
has captured baby Yoda and commits the
biggest crime of the series so far
casually pointing a blaster at baby
Yoda's head the Mandalorian kills him as
he [ __ ] should because if he hadn't I
would have done it myself Pelle tells
the droids to throw his body in beggars
Canyon ding and mando pays Pelle with
toros credits now back to fennec I
thought they had done my girl dirty here
but at the end of the episode a pair of
boots with a cape walk up to her body
and whoever it is kneels down and
playing that she might not be actually
dead I hope not because she is so
awesome but also who is this mystery
Cape where there are a lot of
possibilities it could be Boba Fett or
whatever character bill burr is playing
or CAD Bane another bounty hunter
personally I think it's Giancarlo
Esposito 'he's new character yeah who do
you think kneels over Phoenix body at
the end let us know in the comments and
don't forget to subscribe to new rock
stars for all your baby Yoda needs I'm
Rina Mastro's find me on twitter at
marina masters and please feel free to
tweet all the baby Yoda memes at me it's
how I go to sleep at night bye
[Music]